obviously uh
i i think that was a
momentous day it's been a really
extraordinary two weeks
and after uh the fruitful end of uh two
weeks of negotiations we obviously
arrive
at an agreement and i want to begin
any comments by thanking our
uk hosts this was tough to do
kovid you're all in masks we've all been
operating within coveted restrictions
testing every day
as we should be
and
i think this is hard
you think about it it's hard to pull off
and they deserve credit and the people
here deserve credit everybody who took
part in this
really worked hard at pulling this
together
at a complicated time in everybody's
lives
so i thank the cop president alok sharma
who put together
a strong effort here
and i thank the secretary
of the unfcc patricia espinoza for her
help and she obviously came with certain
experience here
i also want to acknowledge the whole of
government team from the united states
that took part in this and helped us
to do the things we needed to do here to
reach out to people to talk to people to
coalesce
and to make many announcements
that will add to our capacity to be able
to do what we need to do as we leave
here
president biden obviously
made an unprecedented commitment to this
came here made major announcements
premier among them obviously the methane
pledge
108 countries signed up
already and
proceeding to take forward
and also
the ten cabinet secretaries who came
uh he also announced the uh major
deforestation initiative nine billion
dollars
over five years
uh over ten years and uh
that was an important period secretary
blinken
gina mccarthy
50 members of congress the speaker of
the house nancy pelosi
former president barack obama
the united states took this seriously as
we should
after
[Music]
after
the previous administration was absent
during their time in the white house
i also want to you guys know them you've
talked to them uh that's our negotiators
are sort of prime negotiators
what an amazing team and they come
with a remarkable level of experience i
am
in awe of their knowledge
of the
detail of so many different complicated
issues
uh led obviously by souvenirs
john pershing
trigg tally
and
a
whole group of
younger negotiators who
really earned their spurs here some of
them
dedicated exclusively to the rule book
and to the arcane issues of the rule
book of markets of transparency
and they did a hell of a job
so here here are where things
stand in my judgment as we leave glasgow
and i want to thank glasgow the
politeness
and help
from all of the police officers from the
folks at the
at the
security stations the processing of
daily thousands of people was really
pretty pretty impressive
and and the folks here
i mean glasgow could not have been more
welcoming to all of us
in every way possible
so uh
i've been thinking about this for a
couple days but i really do believe
that as a result of this decision and as
a result of the announcements that have
been made over the course of the last
two weeks
we are in fact
closer than we have
ever been before
to avoiding climate chaos
and securing cleaner air a safer water
and healthier planet
because
of this agreement now you may scratch
your head and say well is that hyperbole
no i don't think it is
we've been cruising
uh
all the way up to paris
and paris
[Music]
you know paris was the beginning if you
will when the countries came together
but everybody wrote their own plan in
paris
and they wrote their plan based on less
input less knowledge less science
less
evidence less facts less mother nature
messages than we have had in the last
years
and so those plans if they were fully
implemented
you'd still have a rise of the earth's
temperature to about three point
something degrees if not more higher
four
so paris was a signal the marketplace
not a guarantee that we wouldn't
be able to hold the earth's temperature
rise to well below 2 degrees let alone
1.5
but now here in glasgow
we have 65 percent of global gdp
committed to real plans that have been
certified by the ipcc or by the iea or
by various
uh modelers that you know from rhodium
to climate action to others they've been
certified say yes if you do all those
things you can keep 1.5 degrees alive
and as a result of what took place here
with nations that have never considered
even having the word cold
in a pla in a in a in a plan
where it remains
even today after what took place
coal and the phase down of coal is on
the books
it's part of the decision
and
you have to phase down coal before you
can quote
you know
end coal
so this is the beginning of something i
think you know we always knew that
glasgow was not the finish line and
anybody who thought it was doesn't
understand the challenge that we had
glasgow you know it was never going to
be that we were going to come to glasgow
and everybody was going to have
a decision that was somehow going to end
the crisis
or
you know automatically put us on the
path we have to go
so i would say that uh
you know paris built the arena
and glasgow starts the race
and tonight the starting gun was fired
we have about
nine years within which to make those
critical decisions we were warned about
in 2018 by the ipcc and we have
the years
in this decade the decisive decade
in order to
cut 45 percent
of global emissions to hold on to the
1.5
now
we raised ambition here in glasgow
this was not business as usual
i've been attending these meetings since
when we first created this entire
process
and the story here is not told only
through the ndc's
as critical as they are
the ndc's were the
basic tool that paris did create
but
the fact is that
we saw the full coalition that we need
come together here in glasgow
and
make a commitment and that includes
civil society
private sector
ngos
activists
young people older people
people from all over the world
demonstrating and pushing and the result
is that
we have tribal and indigenous
representatives here
in force
demanding a just transition which is
vital
and demanding environmental justice
which is critical to any approach
so
we had a series of objectives before we
came here
first thanks to many months of
negotiations
the objective we had of
of uh
finalizing that so-called archaic
name the rule book
but the
famous or infamous depending how you
look at it rule book get completed here
folks
that was a goal
and it's hard it was really hard to be
able to do that
there's tough negotiations
over things that matter in the context
of economy and trade and people's
beliefs about
how they should behave in this process
transparency rules how often we report
how we report
uh all of those things progress
uh in order
to to to uh
uh
measure where we're going with the ndcs
and what their meaning is
we set out to raise ambition
and on our team we traveled the world to
do that raised ambition with indonesia
raised ambition with south africa raised
ambition with japan with south korea
with our colleagues in canada
raised ambition
uh in terms of saudi arabia
and and brazil
and so the majority
of the 20 largest economies in the world
which are responsible for 80 of all the
emissions
are among those committed to achieve the
1.5 degrees
and what we believe we're doing in that
raising of ambition is setting a
template
for what we take out to other countries
all around the world
we so rulebook
ambition
third
glasgow gives us a very clear blueprint
going forward for the things we need to
do from now through 2030 and 2030
through 2050
and it embraces keeping 1.5 degrees
alive
it sets out a lot of steps in that
regard while some people may have wanted
even stronger language
the text that we agreed to
has the first ever believe it or not
mention of coal and fossil fuel
subsidies
that's never happened
and it's happened in a way that big
countries that have been dependent on
coal have signed on to phasing down
now does that mean it's phased down no
that's the follow-up that's the
accountability that's the reporting
but
we emerge from glasgow having
dramatically raised the world's ambition
to solve this challenge in this decade
and beyond
and we will have measurements
starting now
every month every day every period of
the year each year